( intro music )
( people chanting )
Stephanie: Child marriage occurs
in more than 50 developing
countries around the world.
And almost always results
in the girl's
removal from school.
What families don't realize
is that by curtailing
girl's education,
they're only perpetuating
the cycle of poverty.
Still, families do this
for a number of reasons.
Perhaps they can't afford
to feed
the rest of their children.
It can create family alliances
and it often settles debts.
Early marriage often
results in abusive
and even deadly consequences.
( bells ringing )
I first ran into this issue
in Afghanistan in 2003.
I was doing a story
on the burn ward
in Herat, Afghanistan.
There several girls had
set themselves on fire
and I didn't understand
why they would do that.
As a Westerner, as someone who
just hadn't had anything
personal in my life
that was so bad that
I would want to do that,
and then I met this
young girl, Marzia.
She was 15 years
old and turned out,
she had been married
at the age of nine.
She had set herself on fire
because she broke her
husband's television set
and obviously was so
fearful of reaction
by him or the family
that she decided to
set herself on fire,
and really that's
a suicide attempt.
While I was in the burn ward,
I met several girls who...
They all gave different reasons
for why they would do this.
Like someone didn't
make the tea hot enough.
It wasn't reasons that
I could comprehend.
The more I researched
about their lives,
I learned that more
than half of those girls
were married underage.
Now, I don't believe
that's the only reason
why those girls did that
but at the same time,
it was a common denominator
I couldn't deny.
I wanted to look at the issues
that would lead to
such a horrific act.
I felt it was a bit
irresponsible actually
as a photojournalist,
the journalist part
being important,
to just show this end result.
I started looking at the issue
of underage marriage,
something I had never
encountered before like this.
I had the great fortune
to meet Malalai Kakar
and she was a police
officer in Kandahar.
Just a powerhouse,
really amazing woman.
She had been working with...
in the police department
for more than 20 years,
even under the Taliban,
only working on women's issues.
I told her what I was
working on and she said,
"Stephanie, this is impossible.
You're never going to
photograph a wedding
here in Afghanistan."
She's like, "I don't even know
if I can even get you
anything like this."
She's like,
"It happens all the time
but I don't know if I can get
you this," and I said "okay."
Then I went back to the hotel
and she called me
that afternoon.
She's like, "Stephanie,
get over here."
She had this young girl Jamila,
which actually means
beautiful in Arabic,
but this young girl Jamila,
she was 15 years old.
She had been stabbed
by her husband.
This is her husband there.
She already had 2 kids
and she had just been
trying to visit her mother
without his permission.
I asked Malalai,
I said, "What's going
to happen to this man?"
And she said, "Nothing."
She kind of scoffed
and then that's when she said,
"Men are kings here."
Unfortunately she was the one
who was later murdered
by the Taliban.
Having worked in the Middle
East for a long time,
I really wanted to make
sure this wasn't something
that was just against
one religious practice.
It's not meant to be
against any religion,
religious practice,
but I didn't want
to single out one,
and so, I went looking
in different countries
and cultures as well.
This series of
photographs is from Nepal.
And this is a village
called the Kagati Village
and it's just only
30 minutes outside of Kathmandu.
This village is known
for practicing this.
There is a day...
It's not Akha Teej,
which they do in India,
but it's a different
auspicious day
where a lot of girls are
married on the same day.
I was able to see several
of these young marriages.
The girls are usually
married between 13 and 16.
It was very difficult
to get access to.
In a lot of cases I showed them
some of the other pictures
that I had done before
and I wanted them
to know that I wasn't ...
You know, even though...
I mean, I was focusing,
specifically in the beginning
of the project,
on kind of
the harmful repercussions
because I wanted that
message to get out,
but at the same time
I wanted to show
the cultures of the weddings
and the beauty in
these cultures,
and that was one of the reasons
why I actually wanted to show
the weddings themselves
because you see all
these beautiful colors.
There are some really
beautiful traditions.
One thing that I learned
was that some of the people
in these weddings
that were participating,
were actually
against the practice
but they were
walking a fine line
between trying to like speak out
but also they were
part of the culture.
They wanted to help me out
and help be their voice.
I also went to Ethiopia
where they have a strong
Christian population.
In January there's
a lot of weddings
up in the Amhara District,
which is where it's most
predominant in Ethiopia.
I went to several weddings there
and this one was
of a young girl.
I think she was 14, Layulim.
Here they actually drape
the sheet over her head
to take her to her
husband's house.
That's when they
were taking her.
Actually she was
one of the girls
who didn't mind that
she was getting married.
She thought she was
gonna have a better life.
She wasn't against her marriage
but they were taking
her to the house
and I asked why is she
covered up like that?
She said, "Well, we
just wanna make sure
that if she escapes,
she can't find her way home,
so she'll have to come back."
This is the first time that
I actually was involved
in the stopping of a wedding.
In this situation,
the mother came over
and she said to my translator
that this girl was gonna
get married that week.
She asked us if we could
stop it and I said,
"I really don't know."
That's not my job to do that,
it's not my position
as a foreigner.
Not even as a journalist
but as a foreigner
and I said, "But, if you want
to discuss it with the sheikh...
And we have our
government minder as well.
"If you want to discuss it
and tell them what you
learned, then you can."
That's what she did.
They made a decision.
Even the government
minder made a decision
to go talk to the head
of the hospital,
not so far away,
and they came back and they
talked to the village about
the physical consequences
of early marriage
and they ended up stopping
this particular wedding.
This is a young girl
who was early 20's
and already had
all those children.
This is a young girl named Asia
and she was 14 and
already had 2 children.
She was still bleeding
from her pregnancy.
She didn't know what was
going on with her body
and that was one of
the scariest situations
is them not knowing what's
going on with their bodies
and why things are
happening to them.
Yemen is one of the places
where it's most predominant.
It's not as reported on
because it's harder
to get statistics
and whatnot from.
But an amazing situation -
I went to one village in Hajjah
and I said, "Can you show me
where there are
some young girls
who are married underage?"
All of a sudden
all these girls come in
and I was like, "Wow,
I was expecting like two."
All these girls were married.
A couple of them had children.
Most of them were about 15, 16.
Most of them were not in school
or had never been in school
and I asked them
why hadn't they gone,
and they said, "Because
there's no female teachers."
When you have a culture
like this,
where if you don't have girls,
who are educated enough
to become teachers,
then how do you
put female teachers
in these rural areas.
Because this isn't Sanaa.
This isn't even Hodeidah.
This is like
the rural village areas.
And so, it's hard
to change a culture,
cultural practices where...
There's nothing for them
to do but get married
if they're not educated
to do anything else.
It was kind of a catch-22
and I felt that that was
an important part of this story.
Thank you.
( audience clapping )
Cynthia: I started in
India in my field work
because it is the case of course
that this happens
a great deal in India
as well as other
countries, and India
being one of the most populous
countries on the planet.
There's a whole area
in Northern India,
the state of Rajasthan,
where this practice
is more widespread
than anywhere else
concentrated in India,
although it does take
place all over India.
And in particular,
there is a season in India
called Akha Teej,
which it's not
specifically marriages
that are regarded as auspicious,
as we came to learn
during Akha Teej.
All new enterprises including
business enterprises
are thought to
have a good start,
if they take place
during this set of
religious and astrological
holidays in Akha Teej.
So I first went...
Stephanie and I didn't
connected until the 2nd trip.
I first went and
spent a lot of time
just in the field,
as Stephanie says,
just talking to people
and coming to understand
how extraordinary,
how extraordinarily
complicated this is.
Here's something that we all
sort of know in the abstract,
but it takes a very
different reality
when you're in India.
Many, many of the
marriages in India
are arranged marriages.
It remains to this day
the most common way
for marriage to occur in India,
for young men and young women.
So the notion that there is
some independent right
for a woman or a girl
to select who she's gonna marry,
is regarded
in many of the most
enlightened families in India
as just nonsensical
because that's not
the way you do it.
A marriage, Indians
would say to me
of all educational levels,
is a joining of two families.
It's not two, excuse me,
two foolish young people
in love with each other
deciding to get married.
There's so very
much more at stake.
So that goes out the door
right away.
Then you think about a village.
A very poor village,
as this one was,
where the only option
for a girl growing up
is to work on a field
in tremendous heat
or tremendous monsoon,
and suffer possibly
the consequences
of having some young man
or boy have sex with her
before she's married,
which in that
culture renders her
basically an outcast for
the rest of her life.
So those are two things
right there
that are very
different from anything
that a typical American
or Western young woman
might have to contemplate
in her future.
This village is the one
that we went to
after weeks and weeks and weeks
of hanging around
on both of our parts.
Stephanie is the most
amazing hanger-arounder
waiting for things to
happen I've ever encountered
and she does it in the most
brutal circumstances
you can imagine.
We had been told that there
were two adolescent girls,
sisters who were
going to be married,
and that it was going
to take place at night,
and that if we were
very careful,
and did all sorts of
elegant negotiations,
and brought some kind of
a token of respect
to the village, we could watch.
We came, we were
prepared for the wedding
of a 12-year old
and a 13-year old
or something like
that we've been told.
This is one of the
teenage girls preparing,
putting on her makeup.
This is a big event
both for the girls
and for everyone in the village.
The entire village is consumed
by the festivities that
are coming to pass.
This little girl was part
of the family that we met
and her face will haunt me
for the rest of my days.
That is very much
what she looked like.
We first saw her
in the afternoon
in her little pink dress as
she was wandering around.
We said, "Who is that?"
They said, "Oh, she's the
cousin of the two sisters."
People were kind of
circumspect about it.
Then they started putting
makeup on this little girl.
I remember this room.
It was a tiny little
room in the village.
It was enormously hot.
Everybody was crammed in there.
Of course, there were only women
as you might imagine,
crammed into this thing,
and Stephanie and
I just sat watching
and we all began to realize
and our translator who
was also a young woman,
began to realize what we
thought was likely to happen.
This horrible feeling
grew in all of us.
Stephanie had been
living with this reality
for many years
longer than any of us
but I think, if I'm
not mistaken Stephanie,
that this was the first time
you had actually seen
a child this young
being prepared for what
looked like her wedding.
The women gathered around.
There were many, many
prenuptial traditions.
Some of which were
quite beautiful
in the tremendous heat.
I remember them walking
with crockery on their head
across a long field.
At one point, the cloth
that you see behind...
They had multiple kinds
of beautiful sari cloth
strung out all over the village
to make canopies, to
make celebratory places
because people were gonna
come from far and wide.
The women are standing behind.
There's the three girls
and they're all bathing.
They're in the dirt
and now they were
washing the little girl
and now we understood for sure
that she was gonna be
part of the wedding.
The proceedings
went on for hours.
That's typical for
an Indian wedding.
It's especially
typical for weddings
in this part of Northern India,
where when they are
breaking the law,
as it's important to
remember they were doing.
This is not a legal
practice in India.
It has not been
for over a century
and that's the case
in most, not all,
but most of the countries
in which child
marriage takes place.
If you go
to the Indian authorities
at the state,
at the provincial...,
local level,
the state level and
the national level,
they will decry this
practice just as vigorously
as anyone here in
the United States would,
but they will also say
it's very difficult to
climb into these cultures
and find out what's going on,
and furthermore,
when you do get the word
of what's going on,
if you try to stop it...
Which way they
will sometimes do.
They will make a great show,
they will throw someone in jail.
You'll have probably
disgraced that family
for a generation to come.
You have probably
not stopped the girl
from getting married too early.
You've certainly
not given her a life
which would be a healthy
option to being married.
What have you done?
It's a huge and complex problem.
The night comes,
the ceremonial fire is lit
and the expression on
the children's face
is one of pretty much utter
bewilderment, I would say.
The extent to which
this young boy,
who is about three years
older than our five year old,
understood what was going on,
it was really not
possible for us to know.
The older brothers
were obviously clearer
about what was happening.
These children were not
and it's also because it's
such a long-drawn-out ceremony,
it has none of what we regard
as the sort of tidiness
of a Western ceremony.
"I now pronounce you husband
and wife". Boom, we're done.
It went on and on and on.
This is the picture
that haunts me still
and the reason I wanted
to show it you afterward
is that this pictures
conveys utterly
the confusing feeling
of that evening.
At this moment,
she's taking a nap.
She's been awaken from her nap
and she's being
carried to the ceremony
and the tenderness that
you see in this picture,
on behalf of the
man holding her,
was absolutely
what we saw there.
It was one of the most
complicated scenes
I had ever seen as a reporter.
Knowing that this
child is going off
to something that is
a horrifying notion to me
and at the same time,
it being very clear
that the people
who were doing it,
including this uncle
who's carrying her,
love her deeply
and think they're doing
the right thing for her.
It is important also to remember
that in India, unlike some
of the other countries,
there is a second
ceremony that takes place.
The plan typically,
although not always,
is that this child
will live at home,
in this case with
her grandfather,
and she will not go
to her husband's family
until she's past puberty.
That second ceremony
was called gauna
and part of what
they do in India
is try as hard as they
can to postpone the gauna ,
but it was the gentleness
with which this man
lifted her from sleep
and took her to the ceremony,
that really haunted me,
and made me realize
how far I had come
from my original
absolute clarity
about everybody involved in
this practice being simply evil.
Now, this child is someone
for whom I want you
to have some hope.
I talked to you originally
about some of the reasons
that a parent, a loving
parent would do this.
You're protecting your
child from possible rape
because you live in a society
in which loss of
virginity before marriage
renders a young woman
an outcast, number one.
Number two, you
know in the abstract
that people from the government
have told you
schooling is important.
But that's kind of irrelevant
when you live in a village
where the only schooling
your child can get to
goes up to fifth grade.
After fifth grade, there's a
long bus ride that's required.
There are predatory
men on the bus
which makes the bus
ride itself dangerous.
If you're in a
culture like this,
you don't send your
child to that school
no matter what a government
person is telling you
about the importance
of schooling.
That stops right there.
If you have no cultural option,
no effective schooling
past fifth grade,
no tradition of regard
for the importance
of individual right
in choosing a marriage,
a clear life
involving rural life,
agricultural work and some
kind of poverty in your future,
what do you do to
protect your child?
You make sure she's
marrying into a good family
and you do it very young
so that she won't be attacked.
She'll have some sort of respect
as a married child already,
and so that there's no chance
that she can go astray.
This child lived in a village
some distance away
from the one we'd
been at previously.
She had been in a school
where the government
teachers understood
how bad child marriage was,
and they had really drummed
into all of the children,
"Don't do this. Don't do this."
Her older sister
was getting married
in a house just
a few houses away
and the night of
the older sister's wedding,
her mother drew her aside
and said, "You too."
Tied a string around her wrist
which was part of
the ceremonial process.
She jumped up
and according to everybody
that we talked to,
including the mother,
said to her mother and father,
"If you do that,
I will call the police
and I will break your
head with a rock."
Those were her actual words.
She ran...
The mom finally said this
to me with some pride.
This was some months afterward.
She ran up the street
to the home of a village worker.
They have these India.
They are paid for,
very nominally, by
the local governments
and their job is
to monitor public health
in a general sort of way.
The village worker went over
with her own parents
and in-laws to the village
and said, "Don't ... "
To this house and
said, "Don't do this.
Let us tell you all the reasons
that this is a bad thing
for your daughter."
Astonishingly finally, there
was a huge row apparently,
the entire village got in on it,
the parents were persuaded.
She was not married off
and by the time I met
her some months later,
she was an avid cricket player
and those are
movie star pictures
that she has up in her room,
and she was preparing to go on
to middle school and beyond.
( lighthearted music )
( calm music )